harcelante tu peux arrêter aux menaces
puisqu'il a agressé l'un de tes amis
c'est ça oui c'est ça il a attrapé un de
mes amis dans la rue avec un couteau il
l'a menacé parce qu'il pensait que
j'aille le rej
oindre plein sinon je vais la tuer je
vais te tuer aussi qu'il allait tuer
tout le monde quoi à la suite de cette
agression il a enfin été condamné
c'était 8 mois de prison mais il est
sorti au bout de trois mois une semaine
après il avait déjà recommencé à menacer
de prison non j'étais pas au courant
qu'il était sorti prison déjà j'étais
choqué qu'il soit sorti au bout de
seulement 3 mois même pas la moitié de
sa peine d'accord et les messages qui
m'ont envoyé ils étaient encore plus
violents encore plus virulents enfin il
disait qu'il allait brûler ma maison me
brûler moi me mettre enceinte mais pas
la fraise il est retourné en prison
quelques jours après que je sois revenu
à Paris parce que j'ai reporté plainte
encore une fois et cette fois-ci il a
pris un enferme d'accord il a fait ça un
enferme il est ressorti oui il est sorti
un mois en avance à peu près sauf que je
comprends pas comment il est sorti alors
qu'en prison on m'a convoqué pour me
dire que au téléphone de la prison il
disait ce qu'il me donne le sourire
c'est de savoir qu'en sortant je vais la
tuer c'est ce qui fait que je me suicide
pas et il est sorti une semaine après
avoir dit ça et ma place et ma plainte a
été classée sans